i feel like i'm being i'm in a
congressional hearing being interrogated
next question
this is awesome
[Music]
[Music]
well oh this time um i i lost i lost
count after 200 so i don't have the
exact number for you i i would say that
the scale of this movie by far is the
biggest we've ever attempted you know so
yeah i i know that we we passed 200 uh
on another film but for sure this one
we we crashed more cars than any other
[Music]
oh man you're you're you're trying to
stir things up huh
[Music]
you know i i i really
it was it was such a like organic thing
i think when i when i when i joined and
um and song hey i actually didn't get to
say i didn't know sun was on this so hey
son hey
nice justin man hey you too
yeah i'm not for the haunted look too
that's right yeah we got him
we're gonna go into the wig business
after the movie
you know i think for me as a as a
filmmaker i feel very fortunate you know
i think when when i first joined up fast
and furious was not the same as fast and
furious now you know it was really just
a car racing franchise and
and you know i was able to enter with
with song and we had such a great time
making tokyo drift and
you know part of the ending of of
getting dom was to really kind of
recognize that this whole universe all
these characters actually exist together
you know and so
i i made a you know i had a great
conversation with vin and we talked
about and we really connected and we
talked about kind of our experience as
filmmakers you know and i i i will you
know definitely was there with me when
we made our credit card movie and i
could tell you you know i think when
michelle a lot of times talk about
us you know about fast and furious she
talks about us representing the group
that was on the other side of the tracks
you know and that that actually really
rings true you know and it feels like
you know we're none of us are supposed
to be here because you know in various
points of our career people are always
saying yeah you you shouldn't be doing
this so you can't do this so you can't
do that and so i think part of what um
we made a pact was that no matter what
if we're lucky enough to earn another
chapter
we're going to defy expectations and
we're going to keep evolving and growing
you know and that was the spirit of fast
and furious you know so when
when sung and i left at six i felt like
this is great we we kind of
we built it to something very special um
it was time to try other things but it
we left it better than we found it you
know and so it was very emotional to
leave but for me
i actually never felt like i fully left
either because like um you know van
would call me the studio was always so
gracious and and always you know
extending open invitation whenever i
want to come back and so i knew that if
i was going to come back it would be
something very organic you know and part
of that is about
growth and evolution and and if we could
tell a story that's more you know
hopefully compelling but we can also
kind of push the scale of things
organically that that is what you know
makes it all worth it
[Music]
you know i i think when when
you know when i left
you know obviously
you know the decision was made that
brian o'connor was gonna
be part of this universe uh even after
paul's passing and
you know i
i think for for for
for me
i think that is something that i will
never take for granted you know and i
want to make sure you know whatever we
do
we do it in a very respectful way and i
think that you know i i think to know
that his character is living on means a
lot i know to me i know to all the fans
and uh it's something that you know
creatively
we're always talking about you know uh
making sure that you know we respect
paul and you know at the same time as
we're building out our next chapters
[Music]
it was very emotional for me you know i
think that i
i think this was something that was very
much earned you know i think that
you know obviously han is very special
to me i i feel like i grew up with han
with song and you know
we've gone through such a great journey
so when we left i felt like okay that's
you know that's it that's the end of our
chapter with this character um but then
when i found out what happened we were
actually sung was with me we're at this
bear luck tomorrow screening at the
egyptian uh for for our 50th 15th
anniversary and one of the fans brought
up justice for han and i was i was
really curious and when they told me
what happened
i was blown away i was baffled i didn't
know like why would anybody do that and
also the treatment to han you know that
that was that made no sense to me
so yeah i i definitely like emotionally
reacted and i had the very similar
reactions with the fans and
and so when i came back it just felt
like wow it's almost like poetic i feel
like movement for justice for han
was needed but at the same time me
coming back felt like oh i get to now
re-engage with han and sung and so it it
felt very much like it was meant to be
you know and i give the fans so much
credit to for them to love that
character so much that when there was
something that was wrong they voiced it
to a point where i think we could have a
real discussion so
having him come back you know that for
us to for all that to happen meant a lot
and so the creative with sung that was
just the icing on the cake that was just
fun you know
yeah you know it's it's a special
opportunity
you know to be able to continue to work
with your friend in this business it's
rare you know you meet so many people
on a set on one project and sometimes
you never see them again but you know
justin i you know we spent most of our
careers together you know and it's funny
how we started with han
and we're now we're back with on but
we're older and i think if you know the
justice for han campaign started a
little earlier i don't think maybe we
wouldn't been ready as just people you
know justin's a father he's older i'm
older
you know life lessons have taught us
certain things that we can put into our
art so
it was an honor to be invited back from
the fans it was an honor to be able to
work with your friend that cares about
this character so much i mean
it means so much as an artist to have
someone care about a character you know
and understand you
deeply enough to know where your
strengths are and your weaknesses are
and to be able to affect people through
a character to do it with a friend that
you started your career with you know
that
journey together is really the hollywood
dream come true you know so
[Music]
yeah you know i think on every level i
think on the on the on the story level
it meant a lot for us to earn that scene
but for you know just us as you know the
cast and me
you know it was just nice to be able to
kind of share that space again you know
and it was it was interesting because we
were we were shooting in in london
and you know i i feel like i saw i saw a
song and you know but i i didn't even
realize the emotional impact it was
gonna have when we were all
in that moment and just reconnecting
that was like
it felt very real and it was a true
connection even though
we had saw we've seen each other but for
that moment to happen um it just it
really did feel like the the weight and
the emotion of it was very true and time
you know time is you know
the test of truth after
years of not seeing each other coming
back together the camera doesn't lie you
know we did miss each other you realize
all those years together and all those
films together there is a
bond you know and we are family and it's
just you know it's hard to describe in
words because it's just something that i
think
we as humans need and we know when it's
honest or not you know and no matter how
dysfunctional our family is we are a
family and it's great to see each other
you know
i feel like i'm being i'm in a
congressional hearing being interrogated
next question
this is awesome
[Music]
well
justin hasn't changed in his approach to
actors you know because
as a director you are the the coach
you're the coach of the team and it's
you know you set the tone you set the
energy
and you know
justin just has a natural leadership
ability you know it's like
being on the basketball team you know
with the with a great coach you know so
the energy and the communication and the
feeling of being supported by the
director has always been there from the
beginning and it's and it
continues and that's why the actors from
the fast and franchising any project
that justin works on
they want to keep working with them they
love it when he comes back because they
feel protected as actors right so that
in terms of his process as a director
hasn't changed but what has changed is
the scope and the level
of
you know ability you know after years
and honing his craft and
still seeing that he has passion for
what he does is inspiring you know some
people
just get jaded they get sick of it and
they don't want to do it anymore they're
doing it for the wrong reasons he's
still here and he's still trying to put
his fingerprint on these films that he
makes and have a deeper message to it
somehow you know and that's exciting to
see because
you know that the fire is going to keep
going you know even if
no matter what success there's always
something more
you know to to to to to mine and to
accomplish on a
on a sincere level right so
you know to see
him stay the same in terms of his
process and his love for actors and the
whole process of filmmaking but to see
the growth right in his craft
it's pretty cool to see as a friend and
and be there together and witness that
you know
[Music]
yeah you know
it's interesting i think for my
experience i remember working with
song and the cast of bear luck tomorrow
it was very evident to me that
it was not an issue of like diversity
and this and that it was just an issue
of opportunity
you know and i i remember before we got
into sundance i i'd call all the actors
together and we
put you know i said look we're gonna do
a screening
and i'm so proud of your performance i
just want you to bring in anybody that
you think can help you in your career
because i don't know where this film is
going to go you know and we had this one
screening and it was like the worst
screening in my life
and these were all people that were
supposed to be there to try to help them
because i just felt like i was so i know
i was baffled
and i realized that you know now that i
have all this time that
people like were so conservative that
they were not looking at them as actors
putting on a good performance they're
looking at them as commodity and going
why would i support them
there's no asian american playing roles
i can't make you know it was a business
thing it was it was so disgusting to me
and so
what i'm really proud of is that that
our film then got into sundance and
everybody's kind of created more
opportunities for themselves you know
and i think through the times you know
going in there and trying to have that
real dialogue was tough it was tough and
you know even when making tokyo drift
but i gotta give universal a lot of
credit because once i had that
conversation
with them they were open to really
changing the process it just makes
cinema and makes tv more interesting you
know and and i think it's it's i have a
lot of hope for the future but i don't
think it's something that we we could
sit here and go oh yeah we're in a good
place let's uh let's call it a day it's
like
i feel like we're still kind of like in
the very early stages of it if you think
about hollywood existed what 100 years
before
i you know i got my chance
and so i feel like with there's still a
lot of growth to be had and the more
people that have opportunities they're
going to have the opportunity to have
those dialogues and that that's what i'm
excited about
yeah and it's like it's it's becoming a
global world more and more each day i
mean when we started the timing was
perfect because it's when
um
most of the asian american students
throughout the colleges in america were
started on email so they were able to
you know
come together and share this information
called better look tomorrow a film that
represented their faces and their
generation for the first time and i
think
you know
opportunities at least the way i see it
now i mean when we were making
better luck tomorrow and tokyo drift
most of the asian american actors i knew
were unemployed there'd be like one or
two of them working and everyone else is
like fighting for scraps and then they
go on the unemployment line but now
the majority are working maybe it's not
you know the characters or the three
dimensions that they're looking for but
there's more opportunities today because
there are more people behind the camera
you know that are making decisions and i
think social media and the internet has
brought people together and now
you know people are demanding to see
their face on screen so it's baby steps
you know and and then you step you know
you take a few steps you know back but i
think through art and films like fast
and furious it shows that
you know diversity can convert to
commerce that there is it does work
there is business by putting people of
all different shapes and colors in the
film so i feel very optimistic you know
and i realized i'm not alone man you
know we got directors we got other
actors we got writers producers in the
game we're all you know we're all kind
of trying to achieve the same thing is
to you know show the world as it is
through our art so very optimistic thank
you thank you so much thank you guys
thank you everyone
you